so what I wanted to do here is have a
discussion about the future and perfect
high end from secret Wars and what I'm
hoping is that at the end of all of this
you'll have a strong understanding of
who the maestro is as well as how he
relates to the Incredible Hulk
and so the Meister was created by Peter
David in 1992 as an answer to the
relationship between Bruce Banner and
his father Brian banner what I mean here
is that while the Incredible Hulk
premiered in 1962 their narrative had
simply shown that he was exposed to
gamma radiation during an experiment
which resulted in the formation of the
Hulk and while there had occasionally
been mention of his parents it wasn't
until 1985 with issue number 312 under
bill Mantlo that Marvel began to provide
an explanation on the history of Bruce
Banner with the introduction of his
alcoholic and abusive father Brian
banner and by extension explained why
the whole came into existence when the
gamma radiation incident occurred now
I'd like you to take particular notice
of what we talked about here because we
transition to future imperfect and the
maestro himself what we'll find is that
this depiction of Brian banner is almost
identical to the portrayal of the
maestro as were shown Brian banner was a
physicist who had worked in the field of
atomic radiation and because of his
exposure to various forms of energy his
concern was that these atomic energies
had bonded themselves to his molecular
structure as a result he'd never had any
intention of producing children but when
his wife became pregnant unexpectedly
the concern of Brian banner was that he
had produced a monster while this seems
to be more due to paranoia than anything
else the fact remained that following
the birth of Bruce Banner because his
mother Rebecca doted over him and
because her attention had been deviated
from her husband Brian
this combined with Ryan's belief that
Bruce harbored modifications to his
genetic structure led him to hate his
son as a result
Brian Banner kept Rebecca away from
their son as often as he could and
instead left Bruce in the care of a
nurse named miss Meacham who would abuse
him both physically and emotionally
furthermore Brian's hatred of his son
intensified when Bruce was given a
building set by his mother demonstrating
enhanced intelligence by assembling the
pieces extremely fast
Bruce's father considered his son to be
a mental freaka due to the fact that he
was able to assemble the set so quickly
lashing out at Bruce Rebecca attempted
to come to her son's aid but was
physically accosted by her husband and
so while Bruce did what he could to help
his father smacked him back referring to
him as a monster now while Brian Banner
would rarely continue to be depicted
during the remainder of bill Mantlo run
because his retcon among others was
received extremely poorly by fans
the title began to slump in sales
leading to bill Matt Lowe's replacement
with Peter David in 1997 with issue
number 331 because of publications were
selling so poorly Peter David was given
virtual free reign over the stories and
during his 12 year run which has become
something of legend he took the concept
of Ryan banner and used it as a way to
introduce the maestro bridging the gap
between the two by way of introducing a
being named Elfie who could see the
future Peter David introduced the
organization called the Pantheon which
operated for centuries from the shadows
and served as a way for Hulk to receive
information which would allow him to
perform rescue and relief missions in
order to make up for his previous
rampages throughout the world because
Delfy was established as being able to
predict the future with uncanny accuracy
while it's only in passing and initially
left extremely ambiguous and Peter David
introduced the maestro as one of
delphi's predictions and stating that at
some point in the future the Hulk would
become the very essence of evil and
dispassion itself and so following up
with this narrative of the maestro
rather than continuing the version of
The Incredible Hulk that we had seen who
had taken the opposite of his father's
abusive methods Peter David introduced a
two-part story called future imperfect
as a way to depict a version of the Hulk
which saw him embracing the abusive
nature of his father
so the story of future imperfect as is
written for secret wars actually borrows
a few concepts from the original and
retcons everything else and so what
we're going to do here is go through the
events as they transpire and fill in the
holes regarding what Peter David took
from the original story in order to
bring us this full understanding of the
tie-in so the story initially picks up
following a woman named Ruby as she
travels into the desert surrounding
dystopia what Peter David does here is
drawn a couple of previously established
elements in order to bring us this
introduction and the original future and
perfect event dystopia was a megacity
formed under the maestro as a last
refuge on earth following the collapse
of civilization after a nuclear war and
for the maestro himself at his base
strength he was much stronger than the
Incredible Hulk due to having been
exposed to the atomic radiation that
came with the nuclear fallout
and so what Peter David also does is
incorporate the character of Ruby and
what were not told why she's here
because there are no other versions of
Ruby who exists within the secret war
science were largely left to assume that
this is the same Ruby who was the
daughter of Cyclops and Emma Frost and
hails from the timeline of Lucas Bishop
something that we had gone over in my
video about his character however as she
makes her way through the desert she
eventually comes across an old man
because dystopia is quite literally a
survival of the fittest world the
mindset of Ruby is that if the old man
is alive she can help him but if he's
dead she'll strip him of whatever he has
and leave his course after arriving
though she finds that the old man is
alive but also learns that he claims to
be Odin of Asgard and the father of Thor
and Loki with the heroes of this reality
having died off long before Ruby came
into existence her knowledge of Asgard
is largely limited to myth and legend
but because she knows enough about the
stories to know that Odin is incredibly
powerful and wise she offers to bring
the man back to their base of operations
which su reveals serves to undermine the
authority of the maestro and remove him
from power
now after arriving in the city the group
is met by a woman named Janus and the
original feature imperfect event
Janus wasn't really the leader of the
rebellion so much as she was the field
commander the real leader of the
rebellion was actually Rick Jones the
grandfather of ganas
and the reason why Bruce Banner became
the Hulk the sidetrack for a second
during the gamma bomb experiment that
transformed banner when the gamma bomb
was set to detonate a life sign was
detect within the blast radius running
out to remove the person before they
were killed
the individual was revealed to have been
Rick Jones who was rescued by banner
which led to his exposure to the gamma
radiation and his transformation into
the Hulk and so getting back into our
story while Janice is a little hesitant
to allow someone into the ranks Peter
David leaves us to believe that ruby has
demonstrated her trustworthiness over
the course of her time with the
rebellion while he doesn't really say
how the result is that once they arrive
within the confines of the base Janice
has a telepath scan the mind of Odin to
ensure they doesn't pose a threat to the
group after which he'll be taken before
the leader of the rebellion however once
a telepath reads his mind her reaction
is one of pain and anguish and she
explains it Odin intends to harm the
group by killing them all at this point
we learned that this man is not Odin and
instead is actually the maestro who was
taken on his form of Bruce Banner
attacking the group and sending everyone
running for their lives
the maestro relishes in the fact that he
had been hunting for the rebel base for
quite some time not only that the
maestro had used his disguise of Odin to
make contact with Ruby after monitoring
her and realizes she was making several
trips into the desert what I'd also like
you to notice is that as he's depicted
here the maestro is vastly different
from the whole that were used to
whenever the Hulk went on rampages more
often than not he was savage and would
seemingly tear things apart without any
true thought other than destruction the
maestro is cunning and obscene but also
possesses the intelligence of Bruce
Banner without the more limitations and
so with the various rebels on the brink
of death and defeat at the hands of the
maestro the conflict is met with the
arrival of the leader of the rebel group
the thing now from here we learned that
this version of the thing is not
actually Ben Grimm in addition to this
Peter David continues differentiating
the version of future imperfect from the
original in the original event The
Incredible Hulk had been pulled from the
past in order to fight the maestro and
end his reign in this story the thing is
actually general Thunderbolt Ross rather
than Susan storm Johnny Storm Reed
Richards and Ben Grimm gaining their
powers by way of cosmic radiation
prior to the global nuclear
or general Thunderbolt Ross and his
commanding officer general Talbot had
been performing a routine mission in
space when the two were bombarded with
radiation Ross wasn't able to keep the
vessel under control and after crashing
to earth
general Talbot had been killed and Ross
was transformed into the thing now
transitioning back to the story
the battle between Ross and maestro
stretches across the length of dystopia
what I also like you to notice here is
that Ross is vastly different from Ben
Grimm where Grimm has more of a caring
nature especially when it comes to
innocent civilians Ross is less
concerned about civilians during the
conflict he even goes so far as to state
that he doesn't care whether innocent
people die as long as he defeats the
maestro while this isn't extremely
important for this story what it does do
is establish the varying differences
between popular characters as they exist
during the secret Wars event and so with
the battle between the two being
short-lived due to the overwhelming
strength of the maestro Ross is taken
back to the castle of the maestro in an
effort to send the rebels into chaos
without a powerful leader now again
something I'd like to draw your
attention to here is Lela Miller when
Ross was captured ruby along with a
couple others make plans to attempt to
enter the maestro's castle but along the
way they encountered the maestro's
hounds which basically operate as his
advanced guard
however amid some of the forces are
layla miller who reveals that she along
with a handful of others are working to
defeat the maestro independently of the
rebels within dystopia now the
importance of Laila Miller is that she
made her debut in Marvel Comics with the
House of M as a mutant who was able to
know the outcome of any and all event to
take place where Marvel largely leaves
us ambiguous and keeps it as a plot
device for stories and future imperfect
Laila doesn't seem to have any abilities
whatsoever and instead seems to have
four digits to combat skills while it
may be that her powers are developed by
her character in future stories as
things transition we pick up with Ruby
and the rest of the group as her led
further into the maestro's castle where
it's revealed that he alongside Ross are
working together temporarily as is
explained to us the goal of the maestro
is to defeat doom and usurp his position
as ruler of battle world
raus simply wants to see doom removed
from dystopia and so in order to achieve
the respective goals
the maestro has to locate and secure the
fabled destroyer of Asgard which would
grant him the necessary power to destroy
doom now because a destroyer armor is in
a hidden location the only way for the
group to located is to violate the laws
of battle world by traveling to other
territories and questioning the locals
arriving at a place called Norse time
which seems to serve as a stand-in for
Asgard and the ten realms the group
arrives at a local bar after trashing
the place and questioning the various
occupants maestro's eventually provided
the information he seeks by a man named
Hodor while this is left largely
ambiguous here what Hodor does is
provide moisture with the location of
the destroyer armor but also stated he
is responsible for the destruction of
Asgard again while this is left
ambiguous the importance of Hodor
statement comes in the fact that he like
others that will find in the various
tie-ins for secret Wars is aware of how
things used to be before the collapse of
the multiverse now once a group arrives
at the location of the destroyer armor
they effectively have to get past two
levels of security
the first is passing you looked at troll
and the second is getting past the
ancient one regarding yulik he's
actually one of the rock trolls that
existed within Asgard while almost
nothing is known about his heritage or
how he came to be
yulik is actually several thousand years
old and is the strongest member of his
race as such his role is to kill all
those who attempt to enter the domain of
the destroyer armor in order to ensure
his protection against those who would
use it for nefarious purposes as
something I'd also like you to take
notice is that Peter David provides us
with a measure of Maestro strength and
relation to other individuals during
their battle we're told that Gulick
possesses the strength of Thor but the
moisture was easily able to overpower
him which establishes that the maestro
is well beyond any other Thor's and
could quite possibly pose a threat to
doom if the fatal power of the destroyer
armor is true and so with you look
forwarded and pushed to the brink of
death he allows the maestro Ross and the
rest of the group to pass and continue
forward to the ancient one however once
they arrived we learned that the ancient
one is not the same being that trained
dr. strange and instead is actually just
Rick Jones then taking the name of the
ancient one because
and cooler rather than putting up a
fight rich Joan simply allows the
moisture to pass however this comes with
a warning of sorts in that Rick Jones
states that the destroyer armor is tied
to the wishing wells of battle world and
that they grant wishes to those who
access them but doom had been notified
of what my sure was attempting to do and
so with doom only minutes away
maestro seizes the opportunity to access
the destroyer armor before doom shows up
in addition to this Rick John provides
one last warning in stating that if the
maestro follows through with his plan
there will be no turning back indicating
that his encounter with doom will result
in his own destruction
however maestro chooses to ignore Rick
Jones and shortly after accessing the
destroyer armor is met with the arrival
of doom god now brimming with both power
and arrogance maestro confronts doom and
actually begins to gain the upper hand
with doom throwing out everything he has
his efforts appear to be in vain as my
show's vast resistance and strength
combined with the destroyer armor allow
him to withstand all of dooms attacks
eventually gaining the upper hand and
destroying doom we learned that all of
this was actually an illusion s Rick
Jones explains the destroyer armor as it
was enchanted by doom grants the wishes
in the mind of its wielder and because
my sure wish to defeat doom the
destroyer armor provided him with the
solution and so as a story begins to
come to a close and Meister reverts back
to his human form of Bruce Banner Rick
Jones reveals that the illusion is
apparently irreversible and Meister will
spend the rest of his days trapped in
his own mind under the belief that he
has successfully destroyed doom and
taken over as ruler of battle world with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end I hope you guys
enjoyed it and let me know what other
tie-ins you guys are interested in
seeing for Secret Wars and I will catch
you guys later peace